well the City of Buffalo buried and
unrecognizable as the death toll from
the devastating Deluge of heavy winds
and heavy snow continues to rise
officials reporting 27 deaths so far in
Erie County New York alone some victims
found in snow Banks and cars after this
blistering blizzard brought even First
Responders efforts at some points to a
complete standstill of victims
apparently dying from exposure according
to officials others lack of heat and
cardiac events after shoveling snow
officials say between today and tomorrow
parts of Buffalo could see up to another
foot of snow hampering ongoing urgent
search and rescue missions happening on
the ground in the region there 400
National Guardsmen on the ground
fortunately we're hearing that
conditions should improve in the coming
days with warming temperatures on the
way but the sweeping Storm's timing it
certainly brought a lot to a standstill
and we continue to see the link
anchoring impacts on travel more than
fourteen thousand flight cancellations
since Friday Southwest Airlines mixing
more than 60 percent of its flights the
airline apologizing to customers in a
statement calling its challenges
unacceptable and promising to urgently
reposition Crews keep in mind flight
disruptions to this degree can take days
to work out